wieso ist hier schon eine fackel ich
habe männer gefunden
und das gilt von nun an für immer also
wenn du möchtest dass dein haus forever
auf jeden fall versuchen mich nicht mehr
also popcorn habe ich schon mal egal ob
aus versehen oder mit absicht das haus
wird trennen wenn ich nochmal schaden
von einem diner taten erleidet okay okay
das ist jetzt echt scheiße ich hab zwei
feuer brennt es brennt
fahrzeugs kaputtgegangen alte halle
komplett ab weil man wirklich dachte ich
habe kein wasser mein wassers weg alter
die kritik
mein wasser spectors der welt nicht in
den wald bringt auch abonniert dann
greift ist doch dein haus über das
komplett aus holz
oh ein heisses wasser
ich weiß nicht wo das wasser hin ist du
hast jetzt bei mir runter und mit
feuerzeug und lauft erstmal schön zu
deinem haus läuft das doch schon zuletzt
das doch schön ist ja nicht so dass die
hälfte schon kaputt ist daher brand
schon abgebrannt ist
ja aber jetzt auch vorbei jetzt vorbei
also jetzt ist also vorbei durch jetzt
geht gerade erst los
plötzlich wollte dass ich den er zurück
battle jakob vielleicht ein jahr gehört
sofort auf ist und was ich mache mir
sofort zehn fahrzeuge
nein lacht wer auf sofort auch für
sofort auf wenn ich jetzt gleich hoch
komme und dann nicht alles auf geld zu
brennen
ja ich bin schon dabei ich bin schon
aber ich bin schon dabei aber bloß hör
bloß auf dass das würdest du nämlich
bereuen was würdest du aber ganz toll
bereuen
you are here das macht man nämlich nicht
mein freund freundchen nämlich so hier
na do
wo bist du irgendwie tief dauern in der
erde das alles gelöscht feier klier oder
sowas
alles alles safe steht noch alles was
die minister oder apps verbrannt so was
du bist so was du bist aber auch okay
ich komm raus mein ganzes unter wasser
alles ist oben kaputt also und da sehe
ich auch was brennen
hör auf egal ich will mir nicht so sein
ich bin jetzt gerüstet hör auf hör
lieber auf ich helfe auch beim aufbau
aber dann lieber auf
ich hätte gesagt ich finde das haus an
ich habe das nicht gemacht ohne vorwahl
und du kannst du immer ohne vorwarnung
von hinten
ich hab gesagt genau gesagt wenn ich
noch einmal schlägt dann wäre jetzt
nicht mehr sagen wer angefangen hat ist
ja alles selbst was du kannst bei mir
rein hat mir wieder den täter gesetzt
ähm ja und das hast du dich dafür dass
sich längst arrangiert was ich schon
viel häufiger irgendwas gemacht als ich
hoffe aber auf das wohlwollen des
freundes zu wollen das wirst du das was
du das machst das was du bereit etwas zu
bereuen
das wüsste wie hast du das hier oben
angezündet wie kann ich hab das dauert
nicht angezündet also ich sehe dich
nicht du bist unsichtbar das ist jetzt
gerade scheiße jener herr wie konntest
du mich ich hab dich gar nicht gesehen
weiß du bist bei mir unsichtbar ja
besser so jetzt sichtlich naja du so
dumm sind diamanten hier unten woher
hast du diamanten
vielleicht habe ich den erfülle
gesammelt die stube schöpft du hast das
erste sich in der aufnahme gebaut und
zweitens hat sie nicht in der höhle
gefunden das habe ich etwas gesagt
gefunden
johanna verrückt bist du auf schlag mich
einmal und ich schlag wieder zurück ich
habe nur gemacht was ich gesagt habe ich
habe auch nur gemacht was sie gesagt hat
wenn es oben nicht fertig ist dann
während des bis ich rauskomme dazu
locker zwei drei minuten zeit ich das
wasser noch was
das wasser weg gemacht dadurch sogar
noch arbeit übernommen maßarbeit was für
arbeit lediglich arbeit zum thema
blinken
jetzt ist er zufrieden
das ist jetzt überhaupt kein frieden ich
habe nicht die ganze zeit nur gewehrt
alter ich war da als alter
ich habe nicht mehr bis auf die erste
die entwickler da habe ich praktisch
nichts mehr gemacht und wenn nur
indirekt da im affekt du dagegen du
dagegen hast dauernd wieder neue sachen
mich dauernd finden gekillt
sie soll allein schon daran wie viele
level tue jetzt verloren hat und wieso
ich diesen zeiten kein level up mich
dauernd getötet hat ich habe aber nie
level von dir genommen
doch nie was bringt mir nicht acht level
hat unter mg eltern sind dass du noch
drei level die kann man nicht diesen
kann man nicht alle zurückbekommen ja
ich habe nie level von dem bekommen ich
habe es auch gerade keine wiederbekommen
ja das ist immer scheiße wenn man dabei
noch sachen weg und dann ist es
irgendwie also ich hab's nicht ich hab
nichts weggenommen
ich hab den ring wird ja alle meine
sachen verloren
ich kann dir zurückgeben aber ein
inventar war fast voll also kann ich
kaum was aufgesammelt haben hat wiederum
auch nicht sein weil ich ungefähr warte
ich so thema ganz ganz nahe sein was wir
hier an wolle zerstört dass sie gern
mehr wiederbekommen
wir haben der farben ich muss jetzt erst
mal holen und ich schaute man bewegt
sich etwa ein bisschen du hast ungefähr
26 fackelt von mir du hast ein schwert
noch von mir dreimal das abkommen
schließen wir sind doch nicht israelis
und palästinenser israel ist das
schlimmer zwischen uns ja dann jetzt
friedensabkommen johanna du hast viel
von mir ja du kriegst es ja zurück aber
der ich habe mir erst mal eine sache um
die pläne hause verlässlich gibt mir
erst mal eine sache und baumann haus
ich habe mein haus auch selber wieder
aufgebaut oder her wir noch dabei
hör auf euch auf womit versuche nie auf
du bist nie auf mit was sollte aufhören
ich habe mich wieder gefährt wenn schon
wäre es jetzt jetzt gewährt wo ich komme
an friedensangebot und mir die idee den
sonst dass er alles notiert
du siehst das alles nur so wie du es
sein willst reiste es ging los und du
setzt was bei mir die druckplatte auch
der versuch ist strafbar den er kann
zwar noch die klassiker zum strafe als
und dann haben wir stich nur getötet ich
habe ja nichts von dem kaputt gemacht
und dann fängst du an
ich habe in dieser folge die ich bisher
nur getötet und ich wusste dass du eh
fast gar keine echten uhr hast mich
dreimal getötet ohne dass auch nur ein
versuch von unternommen habe dich ja
aber ich wusste dass du die level hast
und ich haben die sachen eingenommen
also bzw denen die sachen weggenommen
weil ich genau wusste dass es irgendwie
scheiße wäre wäre ich dann in sachen von
hätte ich habe den habe ich auch nie
getötet 30 level insgesamt meint hier
habe ich hast du mir alle wieder weg
genommen da hatte ich jetzt gerade level
40 oder so man ja weil ich dich nie
getötet hatte als die platte ist anders
als du du hast mich immer getöse als die
level hatte und als ich dein haus
angezündet hast du dann als ich cnt bei
dir hatte
hast du danach ebenso mein haus zum tnt
hingelegt und hast mich getötet hat muss
apple hatte ich hatte dich nicht getötet
als er hier sein aber die sind alle
schweine beginn der ist jetzt neue welt
wenn du weiter weg läuft nicht weg sein
wird ein server richtig groß ist der
neue features kommt kommt hier nichts
mehr hin du depp du jetzt im dschungel
ach so interessant
mein freund wieso ist hier schon eine
fackel
ich habe modfather gefunden wird er was
du wirst sterben trotz allem hat das
kann nicht sein könnten das sozialwesen
von dir alter was ist es also zuerst
richtig scheiße von dir ohne witz war
daran das war richtig scheiße von dir
alter jetzt hören wir mal zu ohne scheiß
was ihr der heißen alles los dass wurden
schwerter rüstungen spürt wie kommt ihr
eine rüstung und schwert während zum
feind der spot sieht der stärker als
buchhalter jetzt hören oktober ist
angefangen hast die druckplatte um
dezent eingesetzt dafür richtig zurecht
gebeutelte damit du deinen lektion lernt
und damit uns lässt dann war wieder
frieden dann kommst du an
baustert diesen diesen diesen komischen
weg da und trost hier zumindest diesen
einen baum da an
und dann ist so hält dir schon klar dass
das vielleicht auf mein haus aber geht
und du so hat es tut mir sehr sehr leid
so ironisch ist also alles ok dann bring
ich dich jetzt um und dann hast du mein
haus angezündet da bei mir alles kaputt
dann habe ich mich ja okay okay da hab
ich gesagt okay jetzt gut
jens kannst es wieder aufbauen innerhalb
von ein paar minuten wäre ich hoch
kommen ist alles wieder in ordnung ich
gehe nach oben das alles in ordnung über
alles wasser und es war sein leben war
immer noch meine damen am rennen gedacht
okay gut pech gehabt dann töte ich dich
halt noch mal dann habe ich das so und
welche auch angezündet alternate
kürbiskopf auf da habe ich gerade schon
gesagt wie hefner stark ja weißt du was
der verein hatte hätte eine komplette
rüstung hatte der ich hab ein schwert
cool
er hat es gibt noch mal alle meine
sachen zurück weil die ligen hier nicht
mehr
ja und dann können wir bitte endlich ein
friedensabkommen schließen blog ein paar
kinder und um zu laufen junge den ich
brauche meine sachen ich schaffe das
hier sonst nicht ja wie letztes mal kam
es dann gebt mir meine sache nicht
kommen und hielt mich jetzt gebt mir die
sachen ja wenn du dein schwert mal
wächst text du hast auch schwert in der
hand
ja weil wir schlecht eine feuerwehrleine
sachen dubai nach höher auf gibt doch
wenn du wenn du über das spät wächst ja
ok ich hab' und gib mir mein tnt weil es
von mir
nein neu sind von dir 1 7 ich hatte acht
und eins davon habe ich ihn gemacht und
das ist auch nicht explodiert das heißt
du hast eigentlich 18 t von mir
vielleicht so 1 verloren aber sieben
hast du auf jeden fall von mir ich habe
aber nur sechs paare sind die antiken 2
ja ich hab so wichtig bei der hingelegt
ich bin sofort hingelaufen dann gib mal
6 ich hoffe das ist alle sind willkommen
ist so aufnahme ist er an das heißt wir
sind gerade ungefähr minute 7 oder so
hier kommt mir mit inventar an
zwar planen ich hab noch nie war ein
aufnahmeritual dort keine spitzhacke
jetzt gib mir meine sachen zurück ich
habe kein abtasten des bauern denen ich
meine sicheren übergang friedensplan
irgendwie klappt man jetzt mehr
was hattest du denn jetzt war also was
du unbedingt von mir brauchst das auf
jeden fall ordentlich tortoise glaube
ich ja ich hatte zwei drei stacks hatte
ich auf jeden fall
dann hatte ich 9 uhr hat er nochmal
reihe 33 schwerter 366 wie sagst du so
viele pixel
ich hab immer ganz viele als ich spontan
damit sich das selber auf dass ziegler
ein sehr fairer tausch wenn alle fälle
aufsammeln ja ich war noch ein schwert
und drive xs du brauchst schwer und ich
hab noch du hast auch ein halbes deck
teile von mir ich habe aber nur zwei
pfeile
dort kann ich sein denen ja ich schaue
mir hinter fleck liegende unten auf
welche ich habe auf jeden fall nur zwei
pfeile auszuführen aufgesammelt alter
das ich habe an pfeil heranzukommen
sollte ich schaue hier auch hier noch
was ist ich habe das gefühl dass sie
langsam die spawn was mit meiner regie
ich baue gerade wie sagtest du eine
rüstung ich hatte eine rüstung ein alter
hut
ich schaue ich mal muss sie erstmal
fackeln kannst auch trage was da drin
ist hast du ihr gefunden seiner
panischen weglaufe aktion aber weil habe
ich ernsthaft nicht
wer trotzdem hast du noch ein schwert
und nel passt eigentlich
er hat heute die pfeile weg all das
waren alle meine freunde die ich hatte
ich will euch mal diamanten und du hast
keine diamanten gefunden nach ich glaube
ich weiß warum der volle rüstungen eine
hab ich auch nicht aber du alles was
nach unten den lagerraum anzuzünden ist
was ganz anderes als ein ic waggon der
obere ist und hässliches anzuzünden
ich wusste nicht dass der sonne
lagerraum ist ich habe schlichten können
hier kann man respekt alltag ist ich
habe extra gedacht dass ich habe extra
gewusst dass kisten nicht brennen
deswegen hab ich mit dem boden
angezündet ich hab mir da schon was bei
gedacht deswegen habe ich auch nicht
oben sofort den dienst zune kisten
brennen wirklich nicht er ist auch ein
wolf boden angezündet habe ich nicht
habe ich mich dadurch angezündet worden
ja aber das wusste ich ja nicht können
wir jetzt ein friedensabkommen flach ja
aber erst wenn ich eine weile zurück hab
ja die habe ich nicht aber ich kann ja
jetzt werde ich leider habt recht
gegeben
ich würde sagen wenn man jetzt eine
spontane wir haben immer noch kein haus
gebaut alter und wir sind schon etwa
drei viertel auf nehmen
wie viele minuten seine folgezeit das
immerhin müsste mal so ein buch
schreiben wir brauchen als nächsten gast
brauchen wenn lothar irgendwie so ein
vertrag schreiben kann ein sohn
minecraft buch und dann kümmert das
unterschreiten
ich kenne ja schon unser nächsten glaubt
nicht dass der das kann müsste ich mal
fragen
er war in dieser höhle oder kunst
studiert sozusagen ich erkunde die
gerade wir waren ja nicht mal hier in
diesem dings ich baue dir nun ganz leise
ab und jetzt eine menge kohle
eisenskulptur wir brauchen ganz viel
eisen für die gestrige stadthaus weil
wir da ganz viele was meinst du das ganz
schön du dahin packen
wie wärs dafür dass wir das beide mache
ich glaube dass eisenach
warum gerade jetzt ich lade hier schon
ja hab ja die leute das machst du warst
mir kommt aber wenn du insgesamt malsch
aus dass ich verloren was du verloren
hast da ist also nicht mal ausgeglichen
das ist also habe ich deutlich mehr
verloren als du 40 level allein schon
ich hatte mehr als 40 level verloren ich
hatte zwar hatte einmal
ich hatte jetzt vorhin hatte ich acht
und davor hatte ich schon mal 30 und
zwischendurch immer mal wieder welche du
hast übrigens noch zehn gebratene
schweineschnitzel familie fällt mir dazu
auf